dear cute site is about to demonstrate
the device that he helped design the
engineer has dragged his cooling system
out to the company carpark to hitch it
up to a solar module the Sun is beating
down perfect conditions for making solar
generated ice the refrigeration unit can
produce six to eight kilos of ice that's
enough to keep 30 litres of milk cool
for 12 hours merely form foam you don't
have any more milk going on and that
means up to 30% bigger deliveries to
dairies so the system will pay for
itself within two or two-and-a-half
years 90 even the price tag for the
cooling system 3000 euros that's just a
fraction of the cost of automatic
milking systems typically used in
Germany the milk can is here for a test
run the company wants to get the opinion
of a local agricultural expert organic
dairy farmer yours of Frieda has agreed
to try out the cooling system you move
to me you might hunt our milk goes
straight into the tank and is cooled
there in other countries it goes in here
fiedel isn't used to this kind of
time-consuming and back-breaking work
his farm is equipped with a lot of
labor-saving devices but the farmer can
appreciate how the cooling cam could
work for a small holder in Africa
[Music]
they're in Vitek Nick the technology is
very simple so there's not a lot that
can go wrong in Germany we usually have
a lot of technologies so a lot can go
wrong and this can hold quite a bit 30
litres is a fair amount in Germany milk
output is high but in Africa one cow
produces just five litres of milk a day
so the 30 litre can suffice is for a
small herd after 10 minutes the 3 6 kilo
blocks of ice have cooled down the milk
considerably is 28 degrees now a 10
degree reduction in heat is a lot for
such a short time
good news for tobias Werner he's the
managing director of Faison which
developed the system in cooperation with
the University of hoenn Heim this Lang
is the seal of London now our goal has
been to help small holders with 2 to 3
cows in tropical and subtropical regions
because they have the greatest need to
cool their milk right after milking
nothing
the first pilot trials are taking place
in City Bouzid in Tunisia 10 dairies
have been equipped with solar modules
and refrigerator boxes produced in
southern Germany the project is being
funded with German development aid
yes it's right Kenya we're already
conducting a second pilot trial in Kenya
just a slightly different focus and
we're working on the commercial side of
things we've put together a set which
has an article number and can be ordered
by a faison he's an opera stage when the
engineers haven't actually seen the
operation on the ground in Kenya
firsthand so how am i dr. Hammond or the
actor we've got the latest photos from
the milk cooling system in Kenya the cow
in right new challenges require new
solutions the team hopes to refine the
cooling equipment based on the outcome
of further tests
prototypes are on their way to Africa
well packed to survive the long journey